all right hey everybody
um the schedule got all messed up today
donald trump was actually scheduled to
speak
30 minutes ago and 50 minutes ago
he was still in washington dc
so a lot of what's going on not making
any sense but it looks like donald
trump's plane is now approaching
uh his first stop in ohio actually
scheduled for two events today i believe
one just outside of dayton
and then going up in what was scheduled
to be 90 minutes from now
for a rally uh somewhere north i forget
exactly where
but i am not going to be covering that
one i am only going to be covering this
one and i have fresh
memes for people and a lot of things as
we are getting back into it from the
vacation many people very anxious
for us to get back from vacation as i
mentioned on i think it was saturday
we did only receive about 40 emails from
people saying
where's the show where's the podcast
where are the episodes where are the
clips
is the show over what's going on
and um we are uh we are here
and uh we are back but we were just on
vacation okay
um let's see here what do we have going
on
chaka seki already came in very strongly
with a super chat
saying when trumpkins fervently chant
fill that seat
are they begging their god emperor to
soil his diaper
in a public forum exactly right exactly
right that's exactly what they're doing
and thanks to chakaseki for that first
super chat and this is actually a great
opportunity to get your super chats
up on the screen for whatever reason
because of the way i have it configured
during the first couple of super chats
they don't show up on screen but you can
just kind of see
the little you can almost see the edge
of one
that's dust knight who signed up on
youtube feel free to send in your super
chat
i'm just going to give an opportunity
for a few more people to get connected
before i
show you some of my fresh memes that i
have
i don't think we're going to have the
plasma song right now people already
demanding very angrily the plasma song
but we're not going to do that right now
um what do we have coming up this week
we actually have a lot of very
interesting things first of all major
major announcement for the david
pakman show anthony destiny
scaramucci ii is going to be
joining me in a couple of weeks no uh
anthony scaramucci donald trump's
former um white house communications
director
he is going to be joining me uh in a
couple of weeks i think it's going to be
very interesting this week we have three
fantastic guests we are going to have
tomorrow on the program
thomas frank the great thomas frank
google him if you're not familiar with
him don't think of an elephant one of
his
seminal works jesse lee peterson
will be joining me on wednesday
on the podcast and will
summer who is one of the top catalogers
of right wing propaganda is going to be
joining me on thursday so it is going to
be an
amazing amazing week
hein says i think we should call these
rallies
trump rona rally not an altogether bad
uh
not an altogether bad name for it i
don't think that that's uh
out of uh out of sorts i don't think
it's out of line to any degree i think
that makes sense
i also am going to be on jesse lee
peterson's program
in a couple of weeks we are still
negotiating negotiating the terms of
that
amy gray says the only thing i will miss
when trump is no longer in office is the
plasma song oh don't worry amy
we've got the plasma song trump can be
gone we'll still be playing the plasma
song
jonathan williams says do you think
biden will recruit saul goodman to help
save trump from stopping
voter count counting votes viewer from
wilmington delaware
thanks for great coverage yes
trump seems like exactly the type of guy
that would hire saul goodman
very very well said i think you are spot
on
completely spot on we're waiting for
donald trump
it looked like his plane was getting
very very close he he may already have
landed even
let me see if i can find uh
maybe we have some other channel with a
different
uh different view and we can see i it
looked like trump was very close
um what other streams do i have
i'm not so sure actually
let's see what else now everybody seems
to have more or less this view
i think we'll see we'll see trump's
plane coming around the corner
very very soon breezy has just
subscribed with twitch prime and says
looking forward to these interviews ps
play the joke theme song this is the
pacman show it's my favorite show
oh you know i'm not sure if i have
those uh theme songs readily accessible
where would they be we have a hole
i have a whole folder of stuff but i'm
not actually sure let's see
wouldn't be under youtube live i do have
some memes
yeah i'd have to look around for it a
little bit
i'm having actually let me check one
other place
you would think memes and funny pictures
but there's nothing in there
there's nothing in there uh social oh
remixes
remixes okay let's see let me play i'll
pick a random one for you
um here's one of the the david pakman
show alternate theme songs
[Music]
very my dark
[Music]
show
anyway so that's one of them we have
others i also have video of another dog
that likes the show let me see if i can
get this going for you
here is uh this is dan's dog let me see
how i can do this
hold on let me switch my shot no this is
a dog
this is a different dog yeah some of you
guys
there was a call last week where a
viewer called in and said they didn't
like what stephen
was doing of course as you know it's
mnuchin it was a really great call
chakaseki says today's press conference
was a tragedy
look at that i'm reading a chakaseki
super chat and the dog is skeptical
about it
blaming woodward for not going public
with coronavirus lies is insane
orange juicillini marches on
yes and we are waiting i guess for the
plane to turn around at the edge of the
runway
must be close to entering our shot here
as
the phones are being held that dog is
locked in not at all like my dad's dog
no
no adhd there so that's exciting and
then what else do i have
i have a couple other memes in terms of
fresh memes um let me show you just a
couple
other ones here um a lot of vacation
related
uh mimetic content actually this
is uh david pakman show returns from
vacation
so this gentleman is happy you can tell
that in this first image they're not
happy
in the second image they are happy so
that's one
um so we've got that and then
here's another one how i feel monday at
three
when the guys have been on vacation for
the last week so there it is
though i'm i'm out of memory otherwise
that's all i've got right now
um okay donald trump arriving here so
we'll we'll have more memes forthcoming
i'm sure you can submit those using the
contact form
uh davidpakman.com
a few other thank yous rjf has
subscribed at tier one
mall cobb cobti has subscribed with
rhyme and be black has subscribed
with prime appreciate that also a big
thank you to steven garman steven garman
is new member number one today at
joinpacman.com
remember that the number one way to
support this program
and the number one way to get on my good
side is to grab a membership
at joinpakman.com okay other super chats
coming in oh by the way
uh eight days from today september 29th
is debate number one
between joseph r biden jr and
donald j trump we will be live
on all platforms and i'm hoping it will
be our biggest stream ever so please
make a note in your calendar
who has a calendar these days uh no but
in all seriousness
we are trying i hope to get to 50 000
live concurrent viewers
from the standpoint of platforms on
tuesday the 29th we're gonna have a big
stream
a phone lines may will open i would even
say
so certainly i hope to see you next
tuesday okay other super chats coming in
let's see here
joey ruggiero says doj labels new york
portland and seattle
anarchist jurisdictions how does this
play out
i don't know if it has any meaning to be
perfectly frank
so we're going to follow that get a
legal opinion
dire dragon has subscribed with prime
and
sup dns has also subscribed
with prime chakaseki says trump is
constantly late because air force one
is so weighed down with millions and
millions of television sets most of them
in the closet well said
um astro lycos says david destiny was
de-partnered
because he basically said looters
deserve to be killed in the street maybe
you could disabuse him of that idea
i've already had two conversations with
stephen kenneth
destiny bonnell the second about it
i don't know that there's much of an
appetite for more
thanks to kaladin for subscribing for 13
months
with twitch prime i appreciate that
very much so sergeant leska
says can't wait to see you on jesse lee
peterson's show david his perspective is
amazing c says what is our plan if the
supreme court gives the election to
trump when biden clearly won
i i don't know what the plan is we need
to figure out
what the plan is jeremy landry says do
you think the white house kitchen staff
feels underused by making trump burn
steaks and mimicking wendy's burgers all
the time
yeah i'm sure the white house chefs are
like what are we doing here
what are we doing that's gastly says how
did your last stream suddenly
end david lost internet connection
for whatever reason since i got back
from my vacation my internet was floppy
for lack of a better term and i did a
full reboot
i think we're good we're it's feeling
really good right now it's feeling like
we're on where the the
the connection is very strong right now
thanks to
edward rangel who is new member number
two today
at joinpakman.com i very much appreciate
that
uh we do have a level three hype train
in progress over on twitch the youtube
and facebook viewers will often email me
and say david what the hell is a hype
train
it's a twitch thing it's an opportunity
to earn
additional emotes over a short period of
time
as the president uh likes to say but we
do have a level three
hype train going right now as we stand
by for donald trump
just outside of dayton
copper has subscribed with the message
love the content let's keep up the
momentum
and have a landslide victory in november
absolutely
absolutely oh people calling for one
more
uh one more whoa boy meets many gifting
five subscriptions i appreciate that
people want
one more uh remix let me do
one more i mean i guess we'll just do
the one that people like the most this
is it hold on
this is the popularity
this one
this is actually the rave song of the
summer at underground coved parties this
is the song people are going crazy with
glow sticks too
oh wait you know what's crazy this is
actually playing at trump's rally this
is not off my computer
[Music]
anyway okay you can check out the
contest where we had like 10
10 or 15 submissions and we eventually
narrowed it down to that one that was
the top track
uh all the kids raving to that one all
right thanks to michael brown
who's new member number three today at
joinedpakman.com as we wait for donald
trump to exit his airplane
uh timmy lundsford wants me to say two
nice things about donald trump okay let
me think
um he seems to have contributed dna
towards the birth of at least some of
his children accurately
is that a thing and
man i'm having trouble beyond that
i don't even know what else can i say
about donald i don't know
he seems to provide his children with
the financial support they need
even if not emotional is that i mean i'm
like trying here i don't know
okay michael kearns sends a super chat
richard says david did you notice that
the north carolina rally almost no one
wearing masks and on
cue when trump started speaking
everybody behind him masked up yeah it
was uh
it was it was optics propaganda for sure
nevertrumper says in what way will dumpy
try and stop counting of ballots the
night of the election
yeah so the plan is they are going to
try to use uh
the courts trump admitted it he says
he's going he needs the courts
to help him win and it will probably be
by making obscure legal arguments that
absentee ballot counting should stop at
midnight on election day
that's that's my guess about how donald
trump will try to utilize lawyers
and courts to take the election
if i had to guess that would be it
thanks to ky
dizzle b for subscribing with twitch
prime
titan cr has subscribed with prime
donkey show now at 12 months on twitch
and commodore scott has subscribed with
prime as well inconsolable says i'm
living in an
air in an anarchist city and it's pretty
great yeah there's been a bunch of
people
making really funny posts on uh on on
twitter
saying um new york is out of control
right now and it's like a 10 second
video of birds chirping and people
biking by
in mostly empty streets it's uh
it's something else chris hyonis
is new member number four today at
joinedpakman.com
very much appreciate that these are
going to be
um these were only scheduled to be
how long was this suppose so let's look
at the original schedule for today
trump was scheduled to speak at five
uh in dayton ohio i think technically
it's outside of dayton
and it was supposed to run for about an
hour and five minutes
and then donald trump moving on to
another
event at seven i don't know if they're
keeping
the rally at seven and this is going to
be a short event
i don't know what they're doing i have a
hard out at 6 30 regardless
uh because i have a few different uh
elements going on tonight
so we will see what uh we will see what
we get i don't i don't really know
what to expect nicholas d
pasquale says the sign says hire
american yet despite
donald's tie makeup and red hats get
desperate donald's thai makeup and red
hats are made in china
check out our fund if you have interest
in investing in renewables
dot co all right very good
uh we are potentially on the precipice
of completing a level five hype train
on twitch corny doggy has subscribed
with prime
and black white rook has subscribed with
prime
and we are almost there we are almost
there
yes if you missed my announcement
earlier
i will be live streaming all four
debates the three presidential and the
one vice presidential
the first one is eight days from today
tuesday
september 29th i don't know the time yet
let's see
september 29 debate time let's see
where it is uh
it's going to be in cleveland 9 to 10 30
p.m eastern time okay so the plan will
probably be
i will start streaming at about 8 40
next tuesday we'll do 20 minute pre-show
we'll have the 90-minute debate and then
if things go well
and i believe that they will we are
going to um
blow open the phone lines it's going to
be crazy that's next tuesday
next tuesday and i do hope that you will
join me
okay megan gattis says explain what
packing the cord is and is it doable
packing the court is
expanding the number of seats on the
court so
typically on the supreme court there are
nine justices
and presidents only appoint new ones
when someone retires
or dies you could pack the court by
saying well we're going to add two seats
make it an 11-seat court
and the president that does that would
appoint two
new supreme court justices now if
republicans control the senate
it will be tough to do biden potentially
could
could pat could expand the court but
the republican senate could block the
nominees
so it is complex um
let's take it one step at a time adam
bubb
is new member number five today at
joinpacman.com i very much appreciate
that
joseph vanskoye our good friend joseph
says current medical student my first
reaction to ginsburg's death
was to look into finishing my training
in canada is that an overreaction
four more years of trump is awful an
entire generation of scotus dominated by
his
appointees is a disaster i can't tell
you
whether it's an overreaction what i can
tell you
is if donald trump does win another four
years
i am going to be thinking very hard
about my next four years and what is
going to be going on
all right as we are now just moments
from hearing from donald trump let me
tell you
i need your help i need your help
fighting
this type of malignancy and the number
one way we do it
is through our membership program that's
our number one funding source we have
total control over it it's not subject
to the whims of an algorithm
so as we see the tangerine terror the
mango menace
uh orange mussolini as some call him
um consider grabbing a membership at
joinedpakman.com
five people have signed up so far i
would love it if we could get to 25
and this is really cheap my friends
really really cheap if you use that
coupon code
2020 now we're talking about two bucks a
month
if you pay for the entire year at once
it's like a dollar eighty-three a month
so it's not a lot of money
it is how we primarily fund operations
at the show and uh i i would really
appreciate it if you signed up if you
can't afford it if you don't like me
if you don't think i deserve it then
don't do it
quite i'm not here to twist anybody's
arm but i am here to let you know
we do have this mechanism called
membership and
it allows us to fund the show so thanks
to jay torres thanks to
rey yaniyabat and matthew cohen
members six seven and eight today
as we are now just moments from donald
trump
getting going let's see what we've got
in terms of music going
[Music]
yep there it is uh and very very cool uh
cool cool soundtrack going on here we
are going to hear from trump may be
abbreviated
may be abbreviated he is scheduled to
speak at 7 00 p.m
uh elsewhere and i believe it's it's
close to it's
about an hour ride from here to donald
trump's next stop so if if he's going to
make it on time
he can really only speak five or ten
minutes i expect him to go
i would guess at least a half hour or
something like that
um big thank you to john welch john is
new member number nine today at
joinpakman.com let's see if i can
squeeze in another
super chat gagan narula says any chance
trump does a few lines before these
speeches slurred speech can be a sign of
cocaine use
i couldn't say but i will certainly be
asking anthony scaramucci about that
here we go well thank you very much ohio
thank you very much
thank you you know this is really not a
rally you know this this has to do with
workers
programs all the things we love but this
is really we call it a friendly protest
okay
and you know what we're protesting we're
protesting stupidity okay because
so many stupid things you see here a lot
of them going but hello
i'll tell you what he's right i mean
that crowd is very stupid to have a
crowd like that right now
what did we win by a lot and your
governor's here and he just said you're
winning by a lot more this time than
last time so that's good
mike thank you very much
[Applause]
but hello ohio and thank you very much
i'm thrilled to be here in dayton the
home of the wright brothers wall
i wonder what they would think when they
see some of these f-35s and these crazy
planes that we make nowadays ago
thousands of miles an hour right hey
what i wonder
audio but i want to just thank the uh
the very hard-working patriots who are
the backbone of america you really are
you're the backbone of america this is
an amazing group of people
this is amazing group you know i'm going
to another very nice spot
in ohio where we do have a rally but i
can't imagine you have many more people
that we have here but they will about 10
times more
now this is for us and our friends and
workers we want
workers 43 days from now we are going to
win this state
we are going to win four more years in
the white house
yeah it's true thank you
thank you people getting banned hard on
twitch that's that's brutal i know you
had your best year
in the history of your state in the
history of our country says that to
every state now
added until the plague came in and now
we're building it up again rapidly but
you had the best year and we're gonna
have
next year will be the best year we've
ever had i believe we'll get rid of you
for sure
psychologically but we're here today to
talk about
jobs we're talking about jobs a very
favorite subject of mine to
know and to understand that the choice
in november
is going to be very simple there's never
been a time where there's such a
difference
one is probably communism i don't know
they keep saying socialism
i think they're gone they've gone over
that one that one's passed already
joe biden spent the last 47 years
shipping your jobs to china
and foreign countries you know that
and i've spent the last four years
bringing the jobs back to our country
and back to ohio
very much i'm sure you all know on
november 3rd
americans will decide whether we
lift our nation to sowing new heights of
prosperity
or whether we will allow a joe biden
sleepy joe
to shut down our economy impose a
4 trillion whether that's with a t by
the way
four trillion dollar tax hike thanks for
the sub gifts by the way guys thank you
coal oil natural gas and ship your jobs
and factories and dreams
overseas to china and countries that
you've never even heard of
put simply if biden wins china wins
if we win ohio wins and most important
biden wins the world wins
because you finally have a president who
puts america first
and i do put america first
[Applause]
i guess that's why almost four years ago
that's why i did this right it's because
of this
probably more than any other reason i
watched the jobs going out
i never saw anything so stupid in my
life i watched the worst trade deals
and we've reversed many of them almost
all of them now but
we've reversed them and again again
we're having the greatest year we've
ever had and it's going to be back very
soon you take a look at what's happening
we're joined today
by a real good friend of mine somebody
that's been with me from the beginning
and i've been with
him from the beginning ohio governor
mike dewine where's mike where's what
where's that on
he's opening up he's awful where's mike
thank you mike thank you mike he's a
good man and lieutenant governor john
houston
okay good guys yeah
good job congressman warren davidson you
know warren
whoa warren that's very impressive
these are real warriors i'll tell you
those you guys like the empty boxes
behind him
hell of a lawyer thank you mike thanks
for all the help too both of you
really appreciate it and a man you know
i i don't know i don't know if you know
him he should become
legendary because when we didn't have a
lot of support
i had a guy named bob paduck you know
bob
and he kept saying every time i said you
know we're not getting the kind of
support from the top people
he said that's okay sir you went up
another two points we won the
state by a lot remember the fake news
well that's
that's a lot of it back there too a lot
of fake
but they were going around mike okay
mike they were going around saying
guys for people saying that i have the
audio too loud so it's distorting
it's the source is distorted i'll look
for another source but it's not it's not
on my end here i heard you cannot win
unless you win the great state of iowa
but they didn't say the great state i
say the great state
and i heard it i i heard it for so long
it would be impossible and then we won
that night by what nine points what was
it bob nine points
we won by a lot in fact it was the first
indication that that was going to be a
tough
ladies and gentlemen not only did trump
win ohio he won by a hell of it i think
it's better but this is as loud as it
goes
and then we then we went onto these guys
that's why i love these guys
we're not gonna miss nobody's messing
with these guys
all right you know they're great workers
but we use them also for security if
anyone gets a little
bit a little bit rough we'll take you'll
take care right fellas thank you very
much
thank you but we wanted big and that was
the beginning of one of the most
exciting nights in history because we
did something in 2016 that was amazing
and
i'll tell you honestly there is more
enthusiasm now
and this is fact in fact they have a new
thing
first of all you know we're working very
hard on getting
a third supreme court justice yeah
working hard i'm going to announce
who that is
the only thing i'll say for the women it
will be a woman
uh-oh there are a lot of angry people
okay here's a question okay it will be a
woman
does anybody here please raise your head
if you have the courage
is there anybody here that insists that
it will be
and should be a man not this again with
the courage please put up your hand
right now
a lot of women here so okay ready
supreme court justice
most powerful most important just the
most important
you know when you become trump's joking
about it at a rally
most important thing a president does is
pick
supreme court and by the way by the end
of the first term we will have
300 federal judges
a record horrifying horrifying
so let's let's give me a free poll we do
this i have such fun with it
we do it give me a free please say i
have sex four with it dodged hundreds of
thousands of dollars the interview like
19 people
which mean nothing here we got a lot of
people so give me a free poll
who would like to see a woman
justice of the supreme court did someone
else know
[Applause]
who would like to see a male justice of
the supreme court
the only one here there is women there
were some women
guys we're going to be the first station
to put an astronaut on nars remember
that
person it will be i have five
that we're vetting right now it'll be a
brilliant person it will be a woman
it will be a woman and we're looking
forward to it we'll probably announce it
on saturday maybe friday but saturday
and it's a big day for our country it's
a big day for you it's a big day for
ohio
and uh so i think it'll be great you
know i always love why i just said that
like big day for ohio and i do it
somewhat routinely
do you ever notice where biden goes out
and he always picks the wrong location
like if he's in ohio it's great to be
in the city great super chat here i like
this one this is a good one
very very well said it certainly applies
he said are we in florida no
you know i did he did that seven times
how do you do that
when you do that you just walk off the
stage it's over
there's nothing you can do you can make
the greatest remainder of the speech
there's nothing you can do to save it
but the people of dayton know
better than anyone the terrible damage
that biden
has inflicted over his nearly 50 years
47 years to be exact can you believe it
for 47 years joe biden
shook the hands of american workers and
then stabbed them
in the back he said washington vultures
i mean think of it all over
and they raked in cash they raked in big
money
where's where's the sun where is he
where's the sun i'll tell you where is
he
what did i say where is
where is he go ahead you know we did
that for fun where's hunter we didn't
it's not fun it's everything
so we come up with these little gems
where's hunter
you know where he is yeah he's in the
basement with his father isis
yeah where's hunter now hunter did very
well he had no job he was
thrown out of the military and he was
thrown out he had no job and then he
goes to
he goes to ukraine and he gets 183 000 a
month
although he had no experience whatsoever
nothing about
uh sort of like trump's kids as you know
was energy
i think they get an upfront payment of 3
million just to be able to get them and
then
think of that can you be 183 000 a month
and 3 million dollar upfront payment how
about that
i take that one myself you know
and then they go to china he walks out
with 1.5 billion dollars to manage which
is millions of dollars there's this
thing that's been happening at a lot of
these rallies where trump riffs about
things that
the audience doesn't understand and
sometimes the audience is so silent that
when someone laughs you you hear
one person laughing i've got some clips
on today's podcast about it it's weird
first grade teachers are desperate to
silence a crowd the way trump is able to
do it's an amazing skill he has
we have a debate coming up and who knows
you know look he's been doing this
[Applause]
you know what he's been doing it for 47
years i've been doing it for three and a
half years so he should be able to beat
me i would think
he's much more experienced he's great
he's a beauty but he betrayed you
he lied to you he abused you which is
why it's time to retire joe biden this
is serious stuff
do we have any teamsters here teamsters
any teamsters here
that's all one
all right well i did a big favor for the
teamsters you know they had a trucking
company i think 30 000 jobs going out
james hoffa called up could you help
could you help could you help
i helped i kept that company going they
saved 30
000 jobs but then every year they always
endorse the democrat
doesn't matter good or bad and james
huff i'm so disappointed in that guy
so i called i said you know i'd love to
get their support oh i'm sorry sir
they've already endorsed sleepy joe
biden
it's like automatic but you know who
doesn't endorse him all the workers
underneath
and they'll either throw him out or
he'll retire
he'll retire what you get tired of
really resonating with the crowd huh
force the democrat because the democrats
do whatever the hell they want
it's uh it's really but the workers the
people underneath the real people
they're with us all the way i've hired
thousands and thousands of teamsters
all the concrete worker buildings in
manhattan
but they just they're just like wedded
it's uh
almost like a habit i consider it a
habit i think it's disgraceful
but i saved this company a big company
good company
great people we saved it and then you
say unrelated totally unrelated
hey we'd love to have well i'm sorry
it's already done
these people are terrible but that's all
right you always have to remember things
though remember you got to remember
right workers
on november 3rd we must turn the page
forever on the failed
corrupt political class non-sequitur we
get so much
things that are so unfair to the rest of
our country and that's why they're
always with that
top level of democrat but the workers
are with us biden is a
die-hard globalist you know globalists
are out you know that right
globalists destroyed that's not code for
jews as it guys know
i really mean it this country was it was
going down
and we stopped it if you look at your
second amendment
if you look at so many different things
no matter what it is
yeah look at our jobs our jobs prior to
the
the plague and now coming back you know
the housing is
a record setting car manufacturing what
do you guys think it means that housing
is record setting is that
home prices new home sales time on
market is really low
new construction what does it mean that
housing is is a record
we closed it up we saved millions of
lives we had no choice you had to do
that and then we
opened it and now we're rocking it's
going good
it's really going good but the democrats
really waged war on the american workers
for
half a century look what they've done
biden's policy has destroyed 60
000 factories and killed four point
think of it
4.5 million manufacturing jobs we
brought back that's
laughably absurd i mean just laughably
absurd right
they said the the magic wand you can't
do it manufacturing jobs are gone i said
really i don't think so
biden championed the nafta disaster and
china's entry into the world trade
organization which was
a total catastrophe that's when china
started going up like a rocket
you know they're considered in the world
trade they're considered a developing
nation no they're not a developing
nation
by being a developing nation they get
all sorts of advantages over us
so we've been protesting it and we do
things that you wouldn't believe you
don't even want to hear about it because
it's disgraceful
really loving it
you might not be able to tell but
there's a crowd there which is over the
united states but no more
what followed was the nothing short and
think of it nothing short of a
blue collar carnage and it was in ohio
and pennsylvania in north carolina new
hampshire
michigan you know how many car plants
we're bringing back to michigan
nobody's ever seen it for 40 years they
didn't build a plan
and now they're building them all over
and i tell countries
i told a great gentleman he just retired
prime minister abby of japan i said
shinzo you got to build plants here you
can't do this you're building your cars
in japan and sending them we want our
cars built here we want cars built here
and then
he said well that's not up to me that's
up to the company that's all right
shinzo i know you can he keeps telling
this story when he was in michigan he
said that all sorts of car plants
went into michigan it's just not true
people it's up to shinzo it wasn't up to
it wasn't up to anybody else but he's
great it's concocted
out of thin air never forget biden's
economic treachery
they will remember in november after
biden betrayed
and think of it all the betrayals on
nafta and china 40
of all of the manufacturing jobs were
shipped out of dayton
now the good thing is your roads you
didn't have a lot of traffic so that's
the good news everything else was bad
right
it was everything else was bad 30 000
dayton families saw their jobs
disappear overnight by 2016
the per capita income in dayton had
fallen 12
below the national average of fifty
thousand dollars remember this
this all tapping wait i mean these
numbers are incredible what's happened
in three years
ohio lost one in three manufacturing
jobs
two out of three iron and steel mill
jobs and half
crowd is silent it is uncanny how these
crowds don't know what the hell they'll
clap for anything
if you cue them in but he just rants
about nothing
far left of his just so you understand
he has no choice it's not him
he's being pulled left you see where
kamala
kamala she's another great one kamala
again
you see your poll numbers her poll
numbers were going down and
i can't nobody treated him worse than to
kamala right
and she said the harris administration
and working with joe biden did you see
that
but he said worse he said the harris
right he said the harris biden
administration
and i heard that i actually heard that
live although it's not real live i'll
tell you it's sort of
half gone it's shot good shot
but what is that harris biden
administration
and that's where it is look this guy is
shot
i mean if he makes it it's it's going to
be i'm going to come back to date and
i'm going to say what the hell happened
i will have lost to the worst
presidential candidate
in the history of politics i really
believe that
the guy can't speak without the
teleprompter although
i'm telling trump's using a prompter
right now you can see the prompter in
the shot
i hope you're right i hope
thank you i hope you're right i tell you
the country can't afford it one thing
i've learned
is that president xi of china president
putin
of russia kim jong-un north korea every
one of these leaders
they're not shot and we can't have
somebody that's sleepy
we can't have a sleepy guy negotiating
more praise for dictators
would they like to see him though did
you see
would they like to see joe
it's their dream to see you how about
iran do you think iran might like to see
joe biden
they'd go back they'd say give me
another 150 billion dollars you know we
gave him 150 billion
we gave him 1.8 billion in cash you know
that looks like 1.8 billion in cash
and i'll tell you what if and when we
went
we will get a call with about nine
seconds after the victory
and it'll be iran's gonna want to make a
deal why hasn't he made that deal now
why
why does iran have to he he could have
made a deal a year ago could have made a
deal two years ago why
he's running as if he can't do anything
until he gets re-elected
i told people i said don't talk to him
now look they want to wait
this is like this is the gift
if they could do that if china could do
it i mean think of it
if russia could do it by the way
nobody's been tougher in russia than men
no with the sanctions of course with the
uh i exposed right north stream ii
that's the pipeline no you never heard
of nordstrom until i came along i said
to germany let me get this straight
we defend germany right we defend
germany
and that's it they don't pay what
they're supposed to pay they're
delinquent
you know they're delinquent so i said to
angela i don't like gongola but i said
but she's smart
you know why should she pay if she
doesn't have to so i said angela so we
defend you
hungary against russia and you pay
billions of dollars to russia
how does that work explain to me what's
that all about but you never heard it
isn't this more of an attack on germany
than russia like isn't this being tough
what is he talking about i'm in theory i
don't know we'll ever get the money you
know
we we sell them but you know he gave
pillows maybe he got him from
mike lindell the pillow man do you think
when when obama when obama sent pillows
over to ukraine i send tank busters they
sent pillows
grain the fake news goes oh let me tell
you we have been very rough
but at the same time we get along i like
putin he likes me you know we we're
along we know
it's bet is it wouldn't you say it's
smart to get along okay
smart finally something the crowd can
react to
president xi but i had and after what
happened here
i'm having a hard time with china i
really am you know they're buying a lot
of
tradio has been incredible uh they have
been living up to it in all fairness the
largest order of corn in the history of
our country largest order of soybeans
largest cattle order but they ordered
less now you understand right if we
wouldn't have been hit with this
pandemic which they could have stopped
uh it would have meant a lot but it just
means a lot less to me right right
so now after selling you out and
bleeding you dry biden
is back asking for your vote yeah
trump's president he was in prime time
which for him was about half time
long time ago i had a friend a senator a
democrat believe it or not i used to get
along with democrats very well
actually better than the republicans but
i won't say that
but i asked him who's your smartest
senator
and he gave me a name this is 25 years
ago i said
who's your dumbest senator joe who's joe
joe
biden oh i see he's he is really yeah
he's the dumbest senator well that's
not dumber than it used to be i can tell
you what a big
criticism
crowd realizing they should probably
clap to move it along
and you can take the gloves off because
you know they do all this disinformation
they make up phony stuff
like the military with what he said i
think it's a disgrace
and he should apologize a source said
i have 27 people that said that's not
biden's story does he trump trump seems
to think that
biden reported that that's bizarre
that's all
really dishonest people dishonest people
no it's a disgrace and nobody's done for
the military what i've done you know
we've totally rebuilt our military
right we've made it stronger than ever
we have the greatest weapons in the
world
we've gotten raises for our great
warriors
our vet has got just got a 91 percent
approval rating the highest
bar vet what's varvaty
they gave it a 91 to va gave it a 91
approval rating so nobody's done more
nobody and we do we have weapons the
likes of which nobody's ever seen before
hope to god we don't have to use them
but nobody has them not china not russia
nobody has the weaponry that we have we
have the greatest
people with adhd don't like the way that
trump
just skips around topic to topic we have
the uh
i call it the super duper missiles like
at a level that nobody's ever seen
before you don't see them either they go
through here they say
boy what happened what was that it's
gone
it's here there it is i hear a noise
over there where is it it's gone it's
over there
but it's uh trump who two weeks ago was
praised for criticizing the military
industrial
complex has spent the last two weeks
bragging about all the weapons he's
buying
2.5 trillion dollars we spent the
greatest weapons in the world the
greatest weapons that
this world has ever seen without a
question i don't have to say what they
are
in fact the fake news said he just gave
away classified information i said no
i just said we have the greatest weapons
i didn't tell you what they are
i could because as president i'm allowed
to do it i mean you know
hillary clinton's the one that gives
away classified information
oh sick burn man
lock her up oh boy
what's with the smacking the lectern
anyway john bolton i mean he comes in
and all he wants to do is go to war with
everybody
if if i listen to that idiot we'd be in
world war ii right now in world war 5.
there it is sir we saw some movement in
china i think we should go to war with
them and i think
russia let's do them both at the same
time let's also go in right now to north
korea
hey do you remember north korea we were
supposed to be in war with north korea
what happened
what happened you know what the press
said
they said it's amazing first they said
it was amazing and those people lost
their job probably
you know this is you know people will
hear this and be like look trump's
against the military industrial complex
he's the guy who keeps us out of wars he
doesn't do all this stuff he said
you know bolton would have brought us to
war he just spent 10 minutes bragging
about how he bought more weapons than
any former president
it's it's outrageous he'll say any he'll
say anything so you can just find
something and say hey that sounded okay
planes we'd hold everything it was a
depleted military
and now it's a very beautiful brand new
we have f-35s in
here stealth they're stealth
this is what i'm talking about we have
all new rockets all new missiles
brand new planes the bombers the the
tankers the
jet fighters what we've done is
incredible and we had to do it somebody
had to do it you know it's
somebody said well we're sort of doing
some damage to our budget i said look
i want to have a strong military yeah he
he wants the weapon so badly he doesn't
care what we do to the budget
walking up we're running up the white
house lawn the beautiful south lawn of
the white house
i'm not going to be saying you know we
didn't do too well with the military but
we kept it under control in the budget
right
now now the military supersedes
everything i don't know to me
i've always heard the supreme court but
to me the most important thing has
always been the military our defense
and our offense if needed
it's like he doesn't even fully know how
to be an authoritarian that he wants to
be
for your forgiveness and he should be
biden supported the disastrous
trans-pacific partnership
this building wouldn't be here if you
ever did that one
which would have been a death sentence
for the u.s auto industry and other
industries
he supported the horrendous korea deal
okay how about the south korea deal
it's a uh disaster so that was a hillary
clinton deal say more about him although
i guess he had you know his advice
hey you know what's interesting with
biden yeah so he always says
why didn't the president do this and why
did the president do that
and why didn't do this and that this and
that oh the guy's been there for 47
years but he just left like three and a
half years ago you know i mean he was
there
right but the question is why didn't
trump do certain things while trump was
president that's the reason why you ask
why didn't trump do it
it's not like he was 25 years ago they
were there three and a half years ago
why didn't you do it sleepy gel but the
career deal and i say it all the time
she said this will create 250
000 jobs and everybody got all excited
all those jobs
the problem was the jobs were all
produced in south korea so that didn't
work out too
250 000 jobs for south korea anyway i
renegotiated the deal in its entirety
now it's a good deal
that was a rip i'll tell you and the
pro-china paris
climate accord it's pro everything is
for everybody but us
that would have cost us trillions of
dollars and we would have had the
privilege of closing down
dayton's privilege probably 25 of your
companies you could have never
you could have never done it's an
anti-america deal
and you know when i did it i thought i'd
be scorned people
understood that it was a total ripoff
they understood it no people want to be
in that deal
joe biden twisted a knife into the hands
and heart
of the american worker but these brutal
betrayals ended
the day i took the oath of office that's
true
trump reads his speeches as if he's
reading a news article about him and
reacts to what's on the prompter
we're almost out of afghanistan as you
know not easy to get out because we have
people in this country the military
industrial complex eisenhower called it
the military industrial complex and it
does exist
it's not easy to get out but we're very
close to getting out here we go and
getting out of the middle east we're
down to very little in iraq we're down
to almost nothing in syria but
you know i will be honest with you we
are keeping we kept the oil
somebody said you still have some salt
yeah that's possibly a war crime
we are almost there my friends we are
one member shy if you look above my head
it's a beautiful thing
remember i used to say a long time ago
before i was
don't go into the middle east but if
you're gonna go in keep the oil but we
went in and we didn't keep anything
and all the death the blood and the sand
i call it the blood and the sand
that worthless sand all of that death
that's been caused for no reason it's
the worst decision
in the history of our country going into
the middle east
we're in there now eight trillion
dollars we're almost down
eight trillion dollars and nothing but
death
and millions of lives if you look at
both sides i'll look at both sides
okay somebody would say oh shouldn't be
looking at the other side look at both
sides
a lot of innocent people were killed we
lost incredible soldiers i see the
the coffins the caskets come in in dover
and i see it and i said oh boy
why why why reports are actually that
trump doesn't go there to dover he went
like once or twice
from the trans-pacific partnership and
saved
that whole business of of so much
i extended the and what i had to do is i
extended for a short time and then
totally ended nafta you know nafta is
the worst trade deal ever made
ever made
[Applause]
and we did the usmca mexico canada we
have a great deal
and the reason i know it's a great deal
because the other sides are
unhappy you always like to have an
unhappy person
that's dangerous no they're okay but
they had a free rip at us for years and
years and years nafta
how many how many buildings how many
factories did you lose
right here where they moved over to
mexico moved up to canada moved
all over the place but that's not going
to happen anymore the new deal makes it
very prohibitive to do that
in 2017 i signed a historic executive
order making it
really something you got to do a little
a couple of little expressions
just go buy american and hi that's a
nice executive order
we're going to make it really something
[Applause]
[Music]
you know life is crazy in politics yeah
biden
runs for president like two or three
times right and i used to call him one
percent joe
and that was prime time for him right
now that prime time is long over
he ends up winning the nomination
explain it but had elizabeth warren left
and been loyal to her communist ideology
you say socialist but it's coming it's
pretty close
capitalist elizabeth warren
but had she left before super tuesday
biden would have lost every state
but she took the votes away from bernie
and bernie's a nice guy you know crazy
bernie he
he is the nicest loser i've ever seen
you know when they talk about
sportsmanship
he got screwed by hillary clinton badly
but not as badly as this time this was
worse
because all pocahontas had to do
is leave a day early she didn't even
have to endorse her
and the votes that she got which weren't
many but far more than he needed because
he lost a couple of states by
literally a small amount of votes he
would have gotten most of those votes he
would have won he would have been the
one we
we fought i don't know who would have
been better who would have been
easier sleepy joe biden or crazy bernie
tell me
sleepy joe who says sleepy too who says
bernie
i don't know electric atmosphere as you
guys can tell the crowd
keyed in hanging on every word from
donald trump
and that's called a negative spirit and
historically that doesn't do that well
if you look at old races when somebody's
getting votes because they don't like
somebody you know there's an ideology
that let's face it
doesn't like me too much somebody said
we don't like his personality i said i
always thought i had a good personality
they don't like my personality who the
hell cares about my president
right right yeah gotta get the job done
see those rough guys over there i don't
like their personality either but they
get the job done right
who the hell cares who cares about that
person
but when sleepy joe was vice president
of other countries flooded our market
thank you
very much who is that wow
good voice have you ever tried opera
good voice thank you but other countries
flooded our market with subsidized
washing machines you remember that
disaster
does anybody know about the whirlpool
plant and clyde ohio is he going to do
the toilet speed the head of whirlpool
came to see me i was president-elect
and he called and i don't know if for
some reason i've heard a whirlpool
i've heard of it all my life i guess i
didn't know much about it
they made washing machines and i never
knew i knew they were dumping steel on
us and dumping certain things but
i didn't know they were dumping
washington dumping flushing toilets
and he said he's they're putting us out
of business south korea
china they're dumping washington they
make washing machines
they dump them into our market they put
everybody out of business
then they charge you a lot of money when
everyone's gone just like rockefeller
used to do right
just like other people do right now
unfortunately but we're trying to track
them down
and i said that's really terrible i
don't know somehow it hit me so we put
a 50 tariff on all washing machines
coming into our country
okay and i visited i visited with
jim jones imagine these workers cheering
for something that makes washing
machines more expensive for them
like that this this is where we are
ladies and gentlemen in this country
the crowd has been dead they finally
cheer
for making home electronics more
expensive for them
you know he's a great wrestler he was a
great one of the best he was a great
great wrestler
really uh a phenomenal wrestler real
champion
ncaa champion and all gym and that's the
way he is he's a tough guy
no games right no games that he works
with our guys here
your guys and uh he was great
but it's jim's area and we went up and
saw the plant
and they're making thousands a day i
mean they gave me a number it can't be
i think they said like 20 000 a day i
said how the hell can you make that many
washing machines
but you know what i'm talking about
congressman right they're making
thousands of washing machines a day
and it's a vibrant company again it was
dead it was going to close
but i evened up the score i put the
tariffs and now what they're doing is
lg and samsung and these companies that
made the washing machine they're now
coming into the united states
all right guys as i said i do have to
run um this was scheduled to have
started
more than 90 minutes ago of course huge
delays made it a late start i did want
to be here for some of it
i think we get the sense i'm going to be
with you guys on a bunch of streams this
week and we'll have the live debate next
tuesday and all of that stuff
uh thank you for joining me that does it
for me if you're really desperate to see
more of this there
are any number of streams that you can
find but i'll be back with you guys
tomorrow